they tell you this and this and that
they want you to meet this condition
okay so let's just start with what I
think you've already established which
is if it's morning that means it's in
the form x squared plus BX plus C so
that's morning a is equal to one if
you've got the axis of symmetry be x
equals negative to the axis of symmetry
of course is minus B on to a right so
minus B on to a that's equal to negative
two but you already know what a is it's
monic right so if a is 1 then that gives
you b is equal to you multiply the two
across and the negative as well you get
for ya that okay so so far i have x
squared plus b sorry x squared plus 4x
plus C yeah x squared plus 4x plus C
okay so this is what I've got now if you
think back to when we were graph you and
I said okay let's just lock a and B in
place and then just very see what you're
getting is the same problem just move up
and down and up and down okay so this is
the kind of picture I'm imagining um x
equals negative 2 sure let's get an
access on me that's my accesses three
so I'm going to be around here right so
I have a concave up parabola and it's
moving sort of up and down here right
now it's tangent to y equals minus X
square so I've got this company down
here okay so you can see why what is the
particular parabola such that I shift it
up like you know this rock on this one
will be too high too high too high or
too low too low there's that one right
in there right that will give me a
particular value of C such that they are
tangent to each other okay I don't know
where they're going to be tangent
exactly but it's going to be somewhere
around there okay now I've got a couple
of approaches right previous questions
that you've had here have lead you
towards working out the derivative of
this thing because you can work it out
it's just too it's possible right and
saying well if I wanted to be tangent
then I simply want this derivative and
the derivative of this to match at a
particular point right and I want them
to intersect at that point okay because
it's not just enough to know to match
you know I can have two parallel lines
that had the same up gradient so the
tickets of the gradients match sorry but
they don't tangent to each other because
they're apart right so I need the
derivatives to be the same but I also
need them to intercept now I could go
ahead and solve that way but that is
hard Paulo reason why is because as I
just said I don't know where they
intersect and it's not immediately
obvious right that's not a a direct path
or an efficient part to get it okay
whereas in a previous question for
instance they said the tangent at x
equals one passes through a particular
point so they give you a lot of
information to tell you where this page
it's going to go but here I have no idea
where they intersect okay so I'm looking
for some other way of doing this some
other know that that doesn't rely on the
derivative
now noticing that they intercept neatly
together okay if I were to find that
point of intersection the way I would do
it is just by solving simultaneously
right here's one equation and he's the
other one okay so this is that point
sorry this will give me the x-coordinate
for where they intersect do you agree
with that now just think about this for
a second this here right when I'm
solving these two quadratics together
all I need to do is just rearrange at a
tiny bit and you can see that this is
itself a dollar quadratic right the
point of intersection is another
quadratic now that makes sense because
remember how i drew a whole bunch of
these green options right so for
instance this screen option up here make
the very highest one it never intersects
with y equals minus x square so they
never intersect what does that mean
about this particular quadratic here
yeah it has no solutions and the way
that I know as those associates is the
discriminant be negative okay so if i
had this x squared plus 4x plus c you
know c equals 5 or something like that's
obviously too high okay then when i do
the description of this thing you'll be
negative okay alternatively for instance
penis once down to low right when i draw
it i get two points of intersection
right for two points of intersection
that means the discriminant will be
positive right for this quadratic that
gives me the points of intersection what
i want of course is i want exactly one
solution right which is where the
description is not positive nor negative
but zero does that make sense so for
this particular quadratic which gives
you the points of intersection I only
want there to be one point of
intersection right and that's the
discriminant feeding the zero so let's
just quickly get this
b squared minus 4 a c the series seat
that's convenient okay so 16-8 c equals
0 right so c is just equal to 2 now
let's just think about this for a second
so therefore what I'm expecting is x
squared plus 4x plus 2 that's what I'm
guessing now you can go ahead if you
want you're done you can you can cheat a
little bit and you can say sorry oh this
you can cheat a little bit eh alright
well this told me that I got it right
how else might we be able to do that we
got it right like we don't get to take
this into the Theon widget to the exam
so how do i if I'm going back and
checking because I wouldn't normally do
this i'd say like I've got an answer it
seems to work i'm just gonna move on we
don't come back to check how could i
actually know that this is the right
answer yeah
you could you know do the river thing
okay yes yes I absolutely could right I
could say all right well I'm um I'm
expecting that these two things will
have the same derivative at a particular
point right what is that point it's
going to be well this is where this is
where they too they intersect right so
if I put in my C equals 2 in there I
find it is 2x squared plus 4x plus 2
equals 0 all the coefficients events are
just a line through like so that's a
perfect square okay like so and so
firstly I've established there is only a
single point of intersection between
these two and yeah my grass not be gross
it should be at x equals negative 1 okay
that should be where that is now I can
go a step further and say all right I
already know the derivative of this
right the derivative of this guy x
squared plus 4x plus 2 is going to be
what is it 2x plus 4 yeah so at x equals
negative 1 this will be 2 times negative
1 that's negative 2 plus 4 so that's
that's positive 2 okay so that's that
one when I think about the derivative of
the other graph which is negative minus
x squared that's minus two x so x equals
negative 1 which is the point of
intersection I put that in and sure
enough i get to it's the same radio I
didn't have to do that like that was
just I wasn't sure like is that really
the answer it's got one point of
intersection at that point of
intersection they show exactly the same
gradient what else did need so just
think right like I said I found this
easier because it's a bit it's a bit
shorter really they're not here's my
solution for the previous one you just
do a little legwork but it's a bit more
obvious what you have to do in that
question they hate you so much
information you're like I guess I have
to use all these bits of information
right whereas here the hardest part was
getting to hear I think that was a hard
time I did it we've got exactly that but
like it didn't show I was like wait like
how did we go from finding the point of
intersection to finding the
discrimination is that yeah sure so I
guess this is why I'd remember what I
said ok you have Samba some general
quadratic right and when we say oh ok
the discriminant that are screaming
being positive that is going to be zero
the discriminating negative okay when we
talk about what those mechs solve this
right we tend to think of it we call
them roots we call their roots and call
that these things 12 right but they are
more than just roots they're just
whatever solves this equation right now
how did I come about with this equation
and the answer is the solutions to this
are where the two graphs collide right
so what I'm really fighting is not roots
being two of them or one of them or none
of them I'm searching for points of
intersection that are two points or one
point 19 points ok so that's why it's
such a big deal talk about the
descriptive because it gives you it
gives you more than just roots it can be
used to find all kinds of things in fact
earlier when we would do a graphing
rational function you can even get like
the range of a function with the
descriptive because you just want to
know where it's real right so I think
once you see pointed it points of
intersection right and I only want one
of them or if you like I want a double
point of intersection just like we say
we want a double root that's really the
insight you need the rest just kind of
falls out that's that's where the
questionnaires really you don't need to
do any this this is just a check ok
snarling tense
so perdu lock the two different
derivatives are equal like x squared
plus 4x plus 2010 you mean like this
problem x squared plus 4x plus 2 equals
minus x squared plus 4x plus 2 equals
minus x squared what about it it's the
derivative so it so these are video
these are the equations of the parabola
these are the derivatives so what did
you want me to do with the derivatives
um so first you know the different with
you Oh column is x squared plus 4 plus 2
wait wait wait for sport that's not the
derivative that's the function itself
right ah this is the derivative yeah oh
yes boy doesn't matters Jeff yep so you
that's exactly the same thing as what we
did here so you can say oh okay even
when you don't know what this is because
the derivative of a function is
irrespective of how up or down it is all
of these green functions are drawn they
all have the same derivative so even
that was still see it disappears so good
so you can say okay I want to know where
these two are equal to each other where
the gradients are equal to and you come
up with the exact visits because you add
the two x over here so you'd about you
take that over they say oh that must be
the point where the gradients are equal
right and then you just move it up and
down you move this guy up and down such
that it passes through x equals negative
1 y equals negative 1 that's where I'm
going through does that make sense yes
so that's another way of doing it you
get exactly the Supertop